(electronic music)
(alarm clock buzzing)
- How y'all doin', we are the Lucas bros,
- Yeah man.
- He's one Lucas bro, I'm the other one.
This is the morning show for people
just waking up like us.
- These are our homies, I guess.
- Yo, we had a wild night
yesterday man, it was crazy.
We played some video
games, smoked some weed,
it was a good time.
Speaking of weed man, I think
we should be the first people
to bring an actual weed dealer on a show.
- Not a fake one, not an actor,
this is a real drug dealer.
Brought to you by Comedy Central.
(harp music)
- They gave us some money,
we figured let's bring
on a real drug dealer.
Why not?
- That's what we gotta do.
(fast violin music)
- We're trying to get a
drug dealer to come in,
do you think you can give me the number
to one of your drug dealers?
(woman laughs)
- You need an actual weed dealer?
- Yeah.
- Not in this neighborhood honey,
I'm not gonna give my name.
- We need a weed dealer man,
do you think you can get us a weed dealer?
- Dealer?!
(censored expletives)
For real?
- Absolutely.
- That'll be my son, he don't care.
- Alright, can you give us his number?
(phone beeping)
- There we go, we got it.
- That's for real though.
(phone ringing)
- [Phone Voice] Hello?
- Yo, what's up man?
We just got your number,
we wanted to know if
we could have you come down
and deliver us some stuff.
It's a really special request man.
(reggae music)
- We want to bring him out,
bring out Luigi the weed man,
the weed dealer.
- Welcome to the show, how you doing?
- Good, good.
- Actual weed dealer.
- This is phenomenal.
- First thing's first,
let's get this right out.
- What is your best selling product?
- Weed wise, it's South
Alaskan Thunder Fuck.
- What makes it so unique, the strain?
- Yeah, it just fucks you up real hard.
- [Keith] How quickly does it fuck you up?
- Right away.
- How did you get into selling weed?
- Smoking weed.
- And the natural progression.
- [Luigi] Yeah, yeah absolutely.
- So, we want to take some
questions from the audience
real quick, you know.
- [Audience member] Do you deliver?
- Right now?
- [Audience Member] Like,
do you have a card dude?
- Yeah, find me afterwards.
- Well we were gonna do that anyway.
- We'll exchange numbers.
- Yeah for sure.
- Luigi, thank you for
coming on the show man,
we appreciate that you're-
- No problem.
- A drug dealer out there
in the streets hustling.
We appreciate that.
- We're very thankful,
we want to thank Viacom
and Comedy Central for
supporting all this.
(harp music)
- We're gonna roll a joint now.
- We're gonna roll one up.
- Thank you Viacom.
- Y'all watch this, man.
(funk music)
(whistle tweets)
- Oh, come on!
(techno music)